in western tennessee not a long drive
from memphis a battle is raging in a
town long troubled by mismanagement and
corruption
mason tennessee is a place that appears
to be set for good fortune ford is about
to build a factory nearby but the town
owes a lot of money and the state says
officials there cannot be trusted to run
their own affairs the local officials
there say they can and they are alleging
racial discrimination in a fight that's
now playing out in the courts our lead
national correspondent that's david
bagno traveled to mason to get the full
story david what did you find out good
morning to you good morning to you my
friend look the officials in mason
believe their very existence is on the
line here okay that's what it all boils
down to there have been years of them
really struggling to get their finances
straight i mean decades okay now you've
got ford coming in ready to build a
state-of-the-art plant there and all of
a sudden as city officials start to see
dollar signs now you've got the state
that's come in and said mason we are
taking over your finances
mason tennessee population just about 1
000 is home to a lot of landmarks that
used to be and that used to be a school
many years ago virginia rivers born and
raised here is the town's vice mayor to
our right there used to be a grocery
store and a tractor trader ran into it
signs of decline are everywhere and now
this town of just two square miles is
losing the ability to govern itself
last week tennessee's comptroller jason
mumpower took over mason's finances
after years of mismanagement and
corruption it's for the good of the tax
paying citizens who are getting nothing
for the taxes they're paying we can't
even pay any other bill over a hundred
dollars without us contacting them and
them giving us permission rivers and
mayor emmett gooden have been on the
town council since 2016. when we came in
we had to fix what was already messed up
because there was money taken from the
town almost a million dollars was had
been stolen from the town the
comptroller who refused our request for
an interview did provide a timeline
showing embezzlement in 1995 and again
in 2012
20 years of late audits in mason nearly
900 000 illegally transferred from the
water and sewage fund into the general
fund so for years the city has
essentially been robbing peter to pay
paul right that's correct but that's not
supposed to happen right what was
happening before we got here so we still
it was already like that are y'all still
taking money from the water fund
to pay for things in the general fund
the comptroller initially asked the town
to surrender its charter which would
have folded it into the surrounding
tipton county government but the town
board rejected that mason's attorney
terry clayton frames the fight in
biblical terms david against goliath
so we're going to continue
to stand up for the righteousness of
this town how many businesses are there
in mason currently right now it's full
not a big pot to draw from yeah in terms
of tax revenue
correct but there's something else going
on in this area the arrival of ford
motor company tennessee gave ford a half
billion dollar grant to build an
electric car plant just down the road
from mason according to local reports
it'll create 33 000 construction jobs
with a nearly 2 billion payroll and once
complete there could be 27 000 jobs and
mason could benefit dramatically from
that just listen to the comptroller
tax-paying citizens have never had an
opportunity like they do now the
announcement last year that ford was
coming seemed to coincide with increased
pressure from the comptroller on mason
to get its financial affairs in order
why couldn't he have come
before now before ford comes
and all of a sudden you want to show up
and make these demands
in court last week the town's attorney
joined by the naacp
asked for a restraining order against
the comptroller accusing him of
discriminating against the majority
black run town of mason the
comptroller's attorney rejected that
accusation the comptroller simply isn't
giving the town equal treatment but the
town
town is being treated similar to
um
that other
localities have been treated in the past
there was white people that were there
when all their money was stolen nobody
showed up
that's strange i understand what the
mayor and vice mayor is saying that like
we're doing our best you got to give us
a chance
the state is saying look there have been
20 years of chances it's not all your
fault but i'm sorry we got to come in
and get it right what's wrong with that
it's too heavy-handed you come down here
you have a civil conversation and not
come down here and tell the folks if you
don't give up your charter we will go
around you okay that's a threat
meanwhile the vice mayor drives around
dreaming
of what mason
if you really love your city
you'll you'll do all you can for your
city you'll do all you can to see it
grow to see it prosper
we gotta come together and stand
together because if we stand together
for the same thing and the right reason
we will be able to grow
so here's the deal the state cannot
force them to give up their charter
but the corruption allegations continued
look just two weeks ago the former
police chief in mason was indicted for
allegedly falsifying her timesheets now
according to local reporting she has not
entered a plea and we could not reach
her for comment i want you to know that
mason mason is really close to the
finish line they have only two hundred
forty eight thousand six hundred and
fifty six dollars left to pay back
before they are in the black
please
it's a very complicated story david uh
it is there's a lot of nuance here there
is a lot of nuance but the town people
are saying look now you're coming in to
try to take it away just as ford is
coming in with this big windfall that
could help everybody and now that they
will be left out in the cold isn't that
right david that's right look yeah
they've been struggling for 20 years
okay there have been multiple
administrations and so the comptroller
listen the comptroller says we gave you
a corrective action plan in 2013 16 and
21 and you didn't take the corrective
action but you got to know that it was
until ford came in and people saw
hundreds of million dollars in dollar
signs did the comptroller come in and
say whoa why don't you give me your
charter and they were like heck no and
he said okay well guess what i'm going
to take over your finances right
a lot of pride involved as well and my
mom lives in a small town unincorporated
they've got a charter there in mason but
you when you have a town like that you
want to protect it you don't want to be
part of the wider state in that way and
now it's all up to the courts right it's
all up to them all up to the judge yeah
we should get a decision uh deal within
the next 24 maybe 48 hours
all right david begneau for us as always
my friend thank you credible reporting
we appreciate it